- No, but that photo, the
meme was seen everywhere
that we showed in 2023.
- So Stupid.
- [Kelly] Did you know that,
(audience laughs)
that it went around?
- I had no idea.
My kids showed me, like,
I didn't know what was going on.
It was ridiculous.
But I was happy people
were thinking of me.
That's all.
- You have, literally, there
are so many memes of it.
Do you have a favorite that you've seen?
- There were a couple that
made me laugh really hard.
There was one with like, I had a bowl cut
and I don't remember what it said,
but it just made me laugh.
I had all the chains around my neck.
- Well, you had a bowl cut,
so right there.
- Yeah.
It just, it got me.
But there were tons of them.
And it didn't stop, you know?
- [Kelly] It's funny.
- It was ridiculous.
- We need to laugh.
- Yeah, we do.
- Yes.
- And it was the goofiest shot ever.
- And speaking of that,
is there ever gonna be a
reboot of "King of Queens"?
People are doing reboots, I'm just saying.
It's, I'm just saying.
- I don't think we can, man.
- [Kelly] Without, yeah.
- Yeah, we got Jerry,
Jerry Stiller was so part of that show.
I would not want to do it without him.
- Yeah, it's such a huge
show in pop culture.
I think people are just like,
ugh, nostalgic.
- I love him.
Oh, I miss him.
He's amazing.
- It's amazing to work with a great cast
that you click with like that, yeah.
- The best, they were the greatest.
Leah's incredible and...
- Love Leah, yeah.
- So, it was so much fun to do
and such a great time in my life.
And it was like, ah, you
know, I get to see it still.
It's on, so.
- Yeah.
- People still come up to me now.
Younger generation.
- Well, that's the thing
with streaming now,
people are seeing it for the first time.
It's like, well, this is older,
but yes.
- Yeah.
- It's brand new for you, I guess.
- It's weird, yeah.
I had hair.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, I know, but you
actually look pretty badass.
- Oh, thank you, thank you.
- I was gonna, I was thinking
that when you walked out,
I was like, no, this is it.
This is a look, this is a vibe.
- Is is?
Okay, it's gotta be.
God made it that way.
- [Kelly] Yeah.